and I always recommend six to seven
follow-ups in an email campaign and you
can spread that out over time and that
means you've got more likelihood to
catch a client when they might be
looking because if you just bus on four
or five emails within like let's say a
full five week period what about in week
eight or week 16 when they actually are
looking higher than the other agencies
sent them an email there's a 100K
clients that I've won that are still
clients today that ignored every single
one of my emails until email six or
email seven or a second or third
campaign in another quarter trying
different angles in terms of subject
lines is the number one thing to get
open rates because if you're not getting
the email opened it's not getting read
so we need to make sure it goes to the
inbox so that's why I was saying black
and white text no links no signatures no
attachments